let me just publicly extend my deepest
condolences to the people of Turkey for
the terrible attack that took place in
Istanbul I had a chance to speak to
president Erdogan earlier today to
discuss with him not only how
heartbroken we have been by the images
of the injured and those killed but also
to reaffirm our strong commitment to
partner witnessed with turkey with NATO
with the broad-based alliance that we've
structured around the world to fight
ISIL it's an indication of how little
these vicious organizations have too
often that beyond killing innocents they
are continually losing ground unable to
govern those areas that they've taken
over that they're going to be defeated
in Syria they're going to be defeated in
Iraq they are going to be on the run
wherever they hide and we will not rest
until we have dismantled these networks
of hate that had an impact on the entire
civilized world and I know that
that view is shared by Mexico it's
shared by Canada shared by all the
people of this hemisphere and it's
shared in every region of the world so
we stand with the people of Turkey and
we intend to do what's necessary to make
sure that these kinds of terrible events
are not happening